we often wonder is it nature or nurture
or is it your new age liberal parents a
study finds Mom and Dad's political
ideology can significantly impact
children's mental well-being turns out
it pays off to have conservative parents
only 55% of adolescent of liberal
parents reported good or excellent
mental health compared to 77% of those
with conservative or very conservative
parents so take a Victory lap folks
anyway the study's author explaining
conservative parents are more likely to
adopt an authoritative parenting Style
characteriz by both warmth and a high
level of discipline I have to go to the
expert here Jesse what do you think I
want to clarify something about my
parents I was not raised by the squad
Dana my parents raised me to be kind be
respectful and to realize that I wasn't
special and they
reminded so we had discipline in the
house I wasn't allowed to walk all over
them there was boundaries in the house
it wasn't like I could just stay up late
and disrespect people and they didn't
teach me that Columbus was evil or you
know that uh you know I had white guilt
or that everybody gets a metal wasn't
like that my mom just loves Democrats
and hates Donald Trump okay Greg do you
remember when Katie Porter the
congresswoman from California she
reported that her daughter couldn't
sleep at night because of climate change
but like why didn't she just say you
don't have anything to worry about go to
bed she couldn't sleep because her mom
was Katie Porter worse in climate change
I think it's Gen X parents and I have no
facts to back that up but I have a
feeling and that's all that matters just
like the a exactly I think that we've
replaced individualism with identity
we've gone from what I do to what I am
and you saw this 60% near 60% jump in
non-binary status in just one year among
uh Oregon students so that's not a jump
in math scores or English scores or
physical fitness scores but in
superficial labels because we've been
incentivized and rewarded such moves
with attention parents do it teachers do
it activists do it makes you feel truly
special The Daily News y Yale daily news
reports that I think if you major in
gender studies 90% chance you get an A
that's incentivizing it ironically
self-labels uh don't make you stand out
that just mean you joined a different
group you didn't lead you followed
that's what you need to teach kids you
need to say that this is Con conformist
Behavior disguised as individualism but
individualism without productive
accomplishment makes you a nobody it
isolates you you shrink your world into
a tribe of one it's interesting you say
that Charlie hurt who we all know in
love he wrote a piece about how his dad
was so proud of him because he taught
him to be a non-conformist and of course
if you know Charlie that is true so look
that column up everybody we'll get a
little reading going judge um when when
you have Democrats who will constantly
say everything is bad like Retta
thunberg right yeah and and they they
actually put her in front of the Senate
and they they want to listen to her and
you have this young person saying the
Earth is going to go away in five years
and then she quietly backtracks it and
they never say anything about that yeah
well because it's it's part of their
ideology it's part of their tribe but
look liberal parents have been pushing
uh what that the world is ending that
climate is killing us that the whites
are oppressors that are irrelevant uh
and no wonder the kids wake up scared no
wonder they're they need psychological
help I have this one article incoming
Democrat wh Katherine Clark recalls
child waking up with nightmares over a
climate change I mean who talks about
that to their kids remember when uh
kamla Harris claimed that climate
anxiety has young people doubting
whether or not they should buy a home or
have children I mean they create this
nonsense so the kids are like all messed
up 80% of conservative parents
apparently the child doesn't get their
way in an argument uh and 53% of liberal
parents say you know the child doesn't
get their way which means that 47% of
the time the child gets their way so I
mean I just think that I have two kids I
was conservative and their father was
conservative and they're successful and
they're pretty balanced Harold I mean
this is just one poll I guess but it
says when you have 55% of adolesence of
liberal parents reported good or like
excellent mental health and 7 % of those
with conservative or very conservative
parents saying mental health that's a
pretty big difference do you agree I I I
do I uh but I'm I'm like you said it's
one poll and I I trust that they got
they got what they uh G these results
from no I think I I agree but raising
kids to me is not a political exercise
it is is a uniquely human exercise I try
my I have two kids nine and eight years
old my wife em and I try to raise our
kids with a set of rules and boundaries
and we hope that within those rules and
boundaries we teach a lot like you you
you said something about what your
parents wanted you to have more than
anything you said your mom which was
resiliency in being able to respond
right because bad things are going to
happen and good things are going to
happen in life we want them to be
curious we want them to be critical
thinkers but at the same time uh we want
them to be respectful and kind to people
want them to know they got to follow our
rules in our house and I think I I don't
know I mean I'm I'm a Democrat my my
when I met her she was Republican uh I'm
still a Democrat and I think my wife is
probably a little more Democrat than she
than she was before that being said um
she's a she's a disciplinarian in our
household we all respond to her
uh Georg we find you have a bed do your
kids have a bedtime we do we have we 8
8:00 there in bed I love that really I
love I mean maybe you could push it to
9: I'm just
saying we tape you we tap you they see
you the morning